- I just feel like, who do you think
the best dancer is on set?
If we're gonna have to be
honest about this conversation.
- I honestly feel like it's me.
(Kelly laughing)
Why are you laughing?
Why are all of you laughing?
- I just love the humble brag.
- No, I--
Don't you think it's me?
- No, no.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Beth] Who?
- I think it goes Cedric.
I actually have never seen Tichina dance.
- Tichina would say it's me.
Tichina would say it's
me, a hundred percent.
- Are you putting a person you
haven't seen dance above her?
- No, I'm putting her at the bottom
'cause I've never seen her.
- [Kelly] Oh, oh, okay.
- I've never seen her.
I'm gonna put Tichina at the bottom--
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She's got the best voice by far.
- By far. Well, not Kelly.
- So I'm gonna go Cedric--
and then I'm gonna say me,
and then I'm gonna say Beth.
(Kelly laughing)
- You saw that TikTok.
(audience laughing)
- We did.
- That's what he thinks that dancing is.
- And Prince, I saw the Prince thing too.
So wait, I have a band,
so I was just thinking
that maybe we could have a dance off here.
I was just thinking.
(audience cheering)
(band playing)
Y'all haven't seen my moves.
Oh yeah, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, wait, I'm doing this.
(audience cheering)
Okay.
When are you going? What do
you got? What do you got?
(Kelly laughing)
Oh my god, I'm not gonna even compete.
- I was gonna do the snake!
I was gonna do the snake!
(Kelly laughing)
We need to do another quick break!
More with Max and Beth after this!
(Kelly clapping)